dirty general Jeff sessions will be in
New Mexico today to speak with southwest
border sheriffs about immigration
enforcement the visit comes as crews
break ground on a new section of wall
along the us-mexico border west of El
Paso the 20-mile project is part of
president Trump's push to stop drug
trafficking and illegal immigration
he is also directed States to deploy
National Guard troops Manuel Bojorquez
is near the walls construction site in
Santa Teresa New Mexico Manuel good
morning good morning that is Mexico just
right there and currently around here
the only thing separating it from the US
are these posts which are designed to
stop vehicles but not necessarily people
that will soon change here outside El
Paso is a new wall that looks more like
this will go up outside El Paso Texas
stacks of steel posts are being prepped
for what will eventually look like this
an 18 to 30 foot wall spanning 20 miles
of the u.s. southern border is gonna be
durable it's gonna be here for a long
time it's u.s. Border Patrol sector
chief Aaron Hall says it will help block
one of the country's busiest smuggling
routes last year El Paso Border Patrol
agents caught more than 25 thousand
people crossing the border illegally and
seized more than 34,000 pounds of
marijuana and 140 pounds of cocaine it's
gonna deter all but the most determined
illegal entrants from entering the
United States here the new wall will
have a five foot plate at the top to
prevent trespassers from climbing over
and the post will be driven into
concrete to keep intruders from digging
underneath we have to have strong
borders we need the wall Congress hasn't
approved the estimated 73 million
dollars for president Trump's proposed
border wall but last year the President
signed an executive order to use
existing money to jumpstart projects
more than 400 National Guard members
have arrived since last week to patrol
the border I think that the rhetoric has
been more harmful than helpful
Republican mayor of El Paso de Margo
worried stronger enforcement at the
border will damage the relationship
between the u.s. and Mexico you cannot
tell the difference between where El
Paso ends and Mexico begins we're really
one community and have been for over 400
years
critics are also concerned about the
walls environmental impact but the
Border Patrol says it works carefully
not to disturb the surrounding natural
habitat the new section of wall is
scheduled to be completed next spring
Nora all right ma'am well thank you so
much